michael saylor just quit his job for
bitcoin what am i talking about michael
sayler is one of the biggest bitcoin
bulls in history and he happens to be
the ceo of microstrategy which has
acquired almost 130 000 bitcoin over the
last two years but now michael saylor
will no longer be the ceo he is stepping
down and transitioning to an executive
chairman specifically to focus on their
bitcoin acquisition strategy michael
says that in this new role he has one
singular focus it is simply to focus on
bitcoin how can they acquire more
bitcoin how can they push bitcoin
forward michael saylor is no longer
going to be involved on the day-to-day
of running the microstrategy software
business he intends to focus more on
bitcoin now of course they've bought a
bunch of bitcoin and put it on their
balance sheet so let's take a look at
how the performance of that trade has
gone so far michael pointed out that
since the company adopted bitcoin its
enterprise value's up 700 plus percent
and microstrategy is up over a hundred
percent bitcoin is up around 100
and things like gold bonds and silver
are all negative now of course some
people will say oh he's just doing this
because bitcoins down a lot but i
actually think they don't understand
michael's conviction michael saylor
believes bitcoin will rise to become the
greatest store of value that is
available to anyone in the world with an
internet connection and as he has done
with microstrategy he's completely
evolved that business into one of the
leading companies in the digital
currency space a lot of the critics
believe michael's simply stepping down
because the price of bitcoin has dropped
so much but i don't think that's true i
wouldn't bet against michael saylor
michael has a deep-seated conviction in
the digital currency and he believes
that global adoption is inevitable he
also understands that bitcoin is likely
going to be the greatest store of value
available to anyone in the world with an
internet connection
michael saylor freeing up some of his
time and not having to run the software
business on a day-to-day basis ends up
being a net positive for bitcoin the
haters are chirping on the internet but
i think similar to how great of a
decision it looks for microstrategy to
have bought bitcoin
we'll look back in a couple of years and
say wow michael saylor stepping down as
ceo into the executive chairman role
that ended up being a massive tailwind
for bitcoin hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time